c'est fini c'est fini
ce qui m'a décidé à en prendre c'est que
je me suis fait voler des agneaux dans
un pré qui avait un mois et puis je
connaissais déjà le patou j'aimais déjà
cette race de chien mais ça a été le
l'élément déclencheur on va dire cet
éleveur de brebis solognote a pris son
premier chien de montagne des pyrénées
en 2008 le patou vie jour et nuit avec
les brebis il les rassure les protège
des voleurs et des prédateurs comme les
renards et les chiens errants j'ai eu
une attaque de chien et c'était avec
deux chiens il y avait trente cinq
brebis et agneaux j'ai eu trois 3 années
au qui ont été qui ont été tuées bon
parce que c'étaient des chiens
spécialistes ils étaient deux et avec
une pâte ou non j'ai retrouvé la chienne
tout le troupeau lairière et et les
chiens coupable il était à 50 mètres des
rosés pu bouger donc elle a rempli son
rôle quand même parce que c'est des
chiens qui tu es tout le troupeau sinon
pour qu'un pas tout soit efficace il
faut presque deux ans d'apprentissage
bien lisse bien jean philippe boué et le
président de l'association des chiens de
troupeaux d'indre et loire
il a été le premier éleveur de touraine
à avoir des pâtes ou le comportement du
chien on s'approche de ses animaux elle
vient vers nous voilà il nous prévient
que l'on rend dans sa zone dans la zone
de sécurité des animaux voilà elle nous
a prévenus et retourne pour rassurer les
brebis et pour se rapprocher du lot à
protéger
mais voilà elle ne garde toujours un
petit peu sous contrôle le but du jeu
c'est ça c'est qu'un chien il soit
il soit dissuasif sans être agressif
pour obtenir ce résultat le patou doit
être né dans un troupeau puis quand ils
arrivent tout jeune dans un nouvel
élevage il doit rester trois mois
presque seul avec les bêtes des règles
essentielles que jean philippe boué
souhaiterait transmettre localement en
fédérant les éleveurs propriétaires de
pâtes ou au sein de son association